je suis déçu par vous cette fille est
déjà brisée en allant à l'école comme ça
elle est couvert elle est couverte d'où
là elle est à poil et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à poil
pour combien de like on fait un petit
frère Lily Adam en plus ça c'est pas
décidé sur la question elle n'arrive pas
à se décider
la vidéo les copains si on atteint plus
de 100000 on lui fait un petit frère ils
veulent pas aller travailler au lieu de
faire
des milliers d'euros de travail ils
prennent les gens pour des milliers
d'euros moments où soumet en fait un
sondage pour faire un enfant
ça va être quoi après à 50000 likes on
débranche mamie enfin c'est n'importe
quoi
ça n'a aucun intérêt en plus ils
prennent leurs abonnés à 500000 likes
ils prennent leurs abonnés pour des cons
parce qu'évidemment que la décision ils
l'ont prise en amont alors je crois
qu'ils ont dit qu'il ferait pas de
deuxième enfant donc franchement c'est
nul quoi
travailler plutôt à chaque fois que tu
veux les insulter eux c'est pas eux que
t'insulte ce sont tous les gens qui like
eux et qui les aiment mais pas du tout
mais tous les ados tu as pas 15 ans tous
les ados qui a 15 ans adorent les suivre
regarde ça comme un feuilleton toi quand
tu tu regardes un feuilleton tu te donne
d'autres conneries
c'est que c'est devenu un modèle de
réussite
du contenu
d'accord
35 ans mon pote et puis comme Guillaume
hein
en Jean-Michel c'est terrible alors ses
cheveux c'est
fini le drapeau mais c'est ce que vous
me disiez en coulisse la tête qu'il a
avec ça
ils sont très bon
[Musique]
elle a fait sensation sur le parking on
a une vidéo de son passage qui a fait
énormément parler
[Musique]
c'est quand même son fond de commerce ça
veut dire que c'est là où on se rend
compte qu'on peut pas mélanger ce qu'il
y a sur Internet
est-ce que c'est grâce à ça qu'elle est
connue sur Internet parce qu'elle danse
extrêmement bien on déplace au jaloux
c'est tout moi
11,4 millions d'abonnés sur insta et
personne ne regardait le programme sur
TF1 ça veut bien qu'il y a pas de
problème
sont des femmes malheureuses
hypocrites qui aimeraient l'avoir dans
leur lit et qui nous
[Musique]
non elle est jeune elle est jolie
rose quatre choses qui émergent les gens
qui regardent et qui sont chez eux dans
le canapé qui s'emmerde des fous mais
non c'est vrai vraiment que les gens
comment tu peux dire
du mal vous prenez les téléspectateurs
pour des abrutis ça m'en fous en vrai
sur ça je trouve qu'ils essaient de
créer des polémiques pour faire exister
les missions on s'en fout Danse avec les
stars cette année les stars en plus de
pas être connu elles sont pas attachante
on n'en peut plus y passe leur temps à
faire les promos des séries de TF1 c'est
plus une émission c'est une page de pub
le seul truc qui était bien c'était le
retour de Jean-Marc Généreux qui a fait
du bien l'émission je crois qui a enfin
un peu l'ADN populaire de dalles que tu
trouves un gars
deux personnes agressent violemment
Keira Maui avec une barre de fer
personne n'est suspecté d'être là
commentaire de cette attaque et sa
coéquipière Aminata Diallo qui
souhaitait l'évangels du groupe et
prolonger son contrat si cette histoire
a connu un coup d'accélérateur c'est
grâce à la découverte de messages
envoyés à ses proches et révélé par la
presse le 17 septembre ce que je veux
c'est jouer à sa place être sélectionné
en équipe de France je vais me
rapprocher d'elle en étant gentil pour
mieux lui prendre sa place de titulaire
des messages troublants mais aussi des
recherches internet incriminantes elle
cherche cocktail de médicaments
dangereux ou encore casser une rotule 4
novembre
elles sont toutes les deux joueuses
voilà pour les téléspectateurs qui les
connaîtraient pas moi je les connaissais
pas
elles sont arrêtées par deux hommes
cagoulés et qui ramraoui et frappé à
coup de barre de fer c'est
ça commence l'histoire oui effectivement
et puis l'ironie même de l'histoire
c'est qu'elle elle sorte ce soir là d'un
dîner de cohésion organisé par leur club
pour voilà ressouder l'équipe à quelques
jours d'un match très important de Ligue
des Champions contre le Real Madrid
Aminata Diallo est maintenu dans la
voiture immobilisé par un par l'un des
deux agresseurs tandis que l'autre
extirp keremy de la voiture et la frappe
à coup de barre de fer en visant et
c'est intéressant entre guillemets en
visant les jambes mais ça travaille donc
finalement semble bien avoir été la
commandité de l'agression
donc elle aurait fait ça pour vous par
jalousie on va voir son avocat dans un
instant qui va une hypothèse c'est
l'hypothèse des des enquêteurs et des
magistrats
il pointe en fait une une dérive une
voilà une rivalité sportive qui serait
devenue une fixation une fixette dans la
dans l'esprit d'Aminata Diallo et qu'il
aurait conduite sur une voilà une dérive
psychologique et même pathologique c'est
en tout cas analyse que font les
enquêteurs les enquêteurs comprennent
qu'il y a un déclic psychologique dans
la tête d'Aminata Diallo c'est aussi ce
qu'on a découvert nous en travaillant
sur sur ce sujet au Parisien c'est que
quelques semaines avant il y a un
rassemblement de l'équipe de France et
ça pour Aminata Diallo comme pour toutes
les joueuses et pour tous les joueurs de
football c'est c'est le sommet c'est le
top bien sûr et
Karama oui et convoqué pas Aminata
Diallo bon déception de la part des nata
Diallo et finalement carrément oui est
blessé et voilà et et Aminata Diallo va
la remplacer au pied levé
et là elle se rend compte que il y a
effectivement une relation de cause à
effet entre l'absence de Keram ah oui et
elle sa participation à l'équipe de
France a réussi c'est comme quand moi et
que Benjamin Castaldi prend ma place
voilà c'est ça
oui nata Diallo se dit innocente
aujourd'hui oui elle se dit innocente et
moi je voudrais dire je viens d'entendre
encore beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites qui sont globalement les mêmes que
celles qui sont dites depuis plusieurs
heures depuis plusieurs jours depuis
plusieurs semaines depuis même plusieurs
mois et je voudrais quand même dire
l'honneur qui est le mien aujourd'hui de
défendre Aminata Diallo parce que c'est
une femme c'est une joueuse
professionnelle un haut niveau qui a
sacrifié sa vie pour le football et qui
est sali lynché mis à l'index pointé du
doigt depuis quatre ans c'est un
déferlement ça fait 96 heures de ça fait
96 heures qu'elle était en un
carcération projectoire vous vous êtes
convaincu qualitinocente je suis
aujourd'hui convaincu qu'elle est
innocente elle clame son innocence et il
n'y a aujourd'hui dans le dossier rien
qui ne permette de relier Aminata Diallo
aux agresseurs et à l'agression qui a
subi kaïraoui j'entends même pas les
écoutes évidemment que les écoutes ça
n'est évidemment pas un élément
l'article du Parisien est un tissu de
mensonge est-ce que les écoutes de la
police c'est juste du bilan
chère Madame reprend les les conclusions
des officiers de police judiciaire qui
est un résumé donc si vous voulez qu'on
aille au résultat
ce qui est un résumé de plusieurs et
long comme résumé si on prend cet
élément là sans exploiter les recherches
qui ont été faites avant et les
recherches qui ont été faites après on
peut faire dire à peu près n'importe
quoi si j'exploitais votre téléphone
Cyril et que je prenais un élément très
précis pour vouloir lui faire dire ce
que je veux en dire j'y parviendrai la
dernière recherche c'est comment bouffer
un cul
oh la tiré par les cheveux et la mettre
dans l'huile par exemple tu dis ça dans
le rapport de c'est pas sur l'affaire
c'est avant hein
mais c'est avant ça dénote quand même
personnalité maître qui peut entretenir
de l'aise des coéquipières êtes-vous
individuellement et collectivement des
béni-oui oui vous descendez de quelle
planète parce que dans le monde du sport
je croyais pas la mairie
pas les gens dans l'huile moi mettre
les boulettes elle dit d'un membre du
staff de son club tu le ce fils de [ __ ]
races le jusqu'au dernier centime près
elle parle de qui
Monsieur Bruno chéroud
on est sur quelqu'un d'autre là
des notes une personnalité
utilise des mots et qui est prête à
aller très loin au moins dans les mots
contre des gens qui l'empêchent qui
l'empêchent de briller mais il n'empêche
de rien du tout au moment de l'agression
Aminata Diallo est titulaire au moment
de l'agression Aminata Dalio Diallo et
tapé en équipe de France je vous
rappelle que kaïra maraoui n'a pas joué
en équipe de France depuis trois ans
donc vous voyez que toute la théorie
toute la fable que vous nous servez à
longueur de journée je parle pas de vous
personnellement mais je parle de tous
ceux qui ont écrit des tissus de
mensonges sur Aminata Diallo ça n'est
pas la réalité vous allez porter plainte
alors contre le Parisien ah bah c'est
c'est une option qui est fortement
envisagée personne n'est capable de dire
qui est l'intermédiaire quoi je vous
explique juste ce point très important
qui est cette intermédiaire qui a envoyé
les quatre jeunes agresseurs ça personne
ne sait qui cette personne aujourd'hui
et bien cette personne elle a tout le
loisir de convoquer les quatre gamins en
disant bah écoutez si un jour vous vous
faites attraper on est bien d'accord que
c'est Aminata Diallo parce que elle
revait aujourd'hui le visage du coupable
idéal et ça factuellement personne ne
sait aujourd'hui qui est l'intermédiaire
qui a envoyé ces quatre gamins il n'y a
pas d'éléments matériels qui relie
Aminata Diallo à l'agression qui a été
formanté contre Keira Amraoui
peut-on porter n'importe quelle tenue à
l'école depuis de nombreuses années la
question fait débat dernièrement une
lycéenne déclare avoir été exclue de son
école c'est pour avoir porté cette tenue
voici ma tenue appropriée qui m'a valu
une exclusion et un avertissement car
selon ma prof et l'administration de mon
école s'est provocateur cette nouvelle
polémique intervient alors que certains
adolescents aimeraient bien s'habiller
comme ils le souhaitent mais cette tenue
elle a rien de choquant
arrêtez on a tous été au lycée comme ça
TOI
me contacter sur Instagram on a tous été
au lycée on a tous été à la fac on a
tous vu des tenues comme ça je pense pas
que les filles moi ce que j'aime pas
dans son message c'est le mot
provocateur ça veut dire quoi sert en
fait s'il y a des hommes qui ont des
réactions déplacées c'est de sa faute je
trouve que c'est profondément injuste et
je pense que blague à part elle est
victime une sorte de délit de sale
gueule inversé parce que vous êtes une
belle fille et qu'en fait les gens qui
ont pris cette décision sont des gens
frustrés et gris qui eux sont peut-être
pas beaux comme elle elle est belle et
ont décidé de la sanctionner pour ça et
franchement il y a pas de quoi virer
quelqu'un pour une tenue comme ça
pas la fille elle est clairement en
soutif là elle a elle a une tenue
d'Instagram et je pense que il se
rendent plus compte de ce qui est la vie
réelle et la vie virtuelle ils sont en
train de tout mélanger et tu vas pas
dans ta vie virtuelle au lycée ou à
l'école c'est impossible c'est pas
quelque chose de normal il y a pas
d'hypersexualisation elle est bien dans
sa tenue elle est bien dans sa vie et on
va la briser en l'avion on va la briser
elle a froid c'est toi qui nous les
brise
sociaux on va briser sa vie prenons
d'une morale
cette fille est déjà brisée en allant à
l'école comme ça
regarde la photo allez on soutien-gorge
avec un truc vert on voit son horrible
c'est c'est descend pour les à l'école
ça c'est que tout ça normal c'est c'est
normal elle est couvert elle est
couverte d'où là elle est à poil et à
poil elle est à poil à l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
il y a une tenue il y a un respect il y
a de la bienséance il y a des codes
sociaux c'est pas Pattaya c'est pas un
doute tu vois c'est pas une règle
bizarre donc je pense que cette tenue
est totalement inappropriée je trouve
qu'elle a eu raison d'être enfin le chef
d'établissement a eu raison de la
dégager et la même manière alors à ce
moment-là le chef le prof il va arriver
en paréo et on tombe et on dira bah
ouais finalement tout ça c'est cool tout
est possible et puis on va faire l'amour
dans la cour de récré ouais ben pourquoi
pas après tout
non mais qu'on s'étonne pas après que
les gens fuient l'école publique et
mettent leurs enfants dans les écoles
privées où il y a des uniformes et les
gens sont tous habillés pareil mais j'ai
qu'une question tu laisses ta fille elle
est à l'école comme ça le truc mais je
discute avec elle on peut discuter et
c'est elle qui choisira en dernier
ressorts tout le temps c'est l'éducation
arrêtez de faire en sorte que les gamins
décident de tout ce qu'on peut créer un
site qu'on y apprend à l'école de quand
on y va à quelle heure quand ça les
arrange explication répond à la question
avec elle elle te dit papa je me casse
en sous-titre
répond à la question est-ce que tu es
avec elle je réponds à vous tiens alors
allez-y honnêtement à son âge là
aujourd'hui sans doute pas mais après je
discute avec elle s'il a envie de se
maquiller c'est l'envie de sa mère
je vais la langue de bois là tu la
laisses partir ou pas dis pas de bêtises
sa mère non moi je serai plus évident si
elle me dit papa je veux vraiment cette
tenue pour aujourd'hui j'accepterai ben
voilà c'est ce voilà donc il l'a dit
excuse-moi mais tu es complètement à
côté c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit fait
tout tous les soirs donc
[Rires]
tu te reprends on est en direct à chaque
fois tu dis des bêtises qui sont énormes
on est en train de défendre l'éducation
défendre certaines valeurs parce que
justement si tu veux que cette gamine
soit un jour heureux dans la vie il faut
qu'elle a un cadre des valeurs le rôle
des parents c'est d'éduquer c'est pas de
pas dire aux enfants fais ce que tu es
ma chérie fais ce que tu veux quand tu
veux
un enfant dans le mur vous caricaturez
pas je t'écoute vous incarnez les forces
de la réaction moi j'essaye d'être dans
le force du progrès de comprendre les
jeunes
parce que c'est embêtant comme
d'habitude parce que vous avez pas
d'arguments donc c'est un problème pour
moi j'ai rien en face de moi
de toute façon
j'aime pas ce que vous faites tous les
sujets
Josiane dont dans la pièce Éric ta pièce
elle tourne autour de l'argent et en
général quand on est blindé célèbre on a
des petits caprices de star n'est-ce pas
Benjamin
j'ai des vrais faux caprices de stars
est-ce que vrai ou faux Mariah Carey
veut qu'un assistant soit toujours
disponible pour qu'elle puisse se
cracher son chewing-gum dans la main
toujours un gars à côté
vrai ou faux le nouveau roi Charles III
exige que sa lunette de WC le suivent
partout où il va oui c'est vrai genre
il a une station-service
il est pas bien le gars va lui mettre la
lunette il ne suit en permanence avec la
lunette
parce que c'est tellement plein de
microbes moi si j'étais roi pareil
vrai ou faux Lady Gaga ici je la
présente dans sa chambre d'hôtel d'un
mannequin en plastique de genre féminin
avec les poils pubiens roses
je veux pas savoir mais chaque prime de
Secret Story Benjamin Castaldi
souhaitait rentrer chez lui
exclusivement en hélicoptère
mais bon c'était pas quoi c'est vrai
c'était pas tous les jours mais c'est
vrai bah bien sûr c'était une fois par
semaine
le prime c'est un prime Hebdo non mais
tu avais pété un câble je vous raconte
l'histoire ou pas oui à l'époque à
l'époque j'étais je divorcé bah comme
toujours et
[Applaudissements]
donc
je voulais juste rentrer une fois par
semaine à la campagne pour vous pouvoir
coucher mon petit et la seule façon de
le faire ça dépend d'un hélicoptère à
après l'émission donc du jeudi je crois
et donc j'avais mais j'ai payé la moitié
il payait d'accord ça coûtait combien
cette connerie ça devait être 4000 euros
de l'heure un truc comme ça il y avait
combien d'heures
une heure et demie une heure et demie
donc dans 6000 euros cette affaire et le
pilote dans mes gémoins parce que je
repartais dans le culottes
à quel moment tu vas nous dire qu'il y a
eu un bail avec le pilote
regarde l'hélico tu payes illico toute
la nuit c'est comme un jet privé ah bah
c'est ça non mais moi j'avais beaucoup
de mon avis ça te coûter 10000 euros
cette affaire non non il a vérité
Castaldi bah non moi la moitié déjà mais
ça me coûte peut-être
TF1
la moitié
pour que tu ailles en hélicoptère faire
le couillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]